next the pen american center hosts
readings about torture detention and
oppression with authors salman rushdie
sandra cisneros walter mosley edward
alde and others this event from cooper
union in new york city is about an hour
40 minutes
thank you
thank you good evening
wonderful to see so many of you here and
welcome i'm salman rushdie i'm president
of pan american center and
welcome to the second of our state of
emergency
programs
this one specifically to talk about
to put it simply torture
but just before we start i wanted to
make one small announcement about
what penn has been doing the pen writers
fund has been doing about hurricane
relief
um
in response to the hurricanes um we
earmarked certain amount of matthews 15
000 pounds to assist professional
writers
and translators and editors literary
agents who lost
a lot of you know lost their homes or in
in in full or in part in the floods and
we have so far made grants to 24 writers
but uh of 13 000 but but the need is
still great so
there's a number of things you can do
first of all if you know the whereabouts
of a professional writer from the region
who's been affected by either katrina or
rita you can please direct them to to
our website to www
where they can download an application
form or they can email or you can email
us at penn penn dot org
or you can give us some money there
should be people around with buckets you
could make donations tonight or you can
do it through the website again
www.penn.org
thank you
the reason that we're here tonight
i think it's not just we're not just
here as as
as writers and as um
people with consciences but because penn
is an organization that has dealt with
the subject of torture and arbitrary
detention
around the world in many other countries
and has become very
disturbed by the fact that that subject
is now a subject
for the united states as well and i
certainly we feel that if we do not
pursue the problem as
energetically
in this country as we have done in the
past elsewhere that enormously reduces
our voice
when we come to speak about these abuses
in other countries
this is
amazingly given that we planned this
this evening some time ago this could
not be a more topical moment to be
discussing this subject
this is a really important moment in the
debate over the use of torture in the
united states um given that the mccain
amendment is on the table
and the bush administration is exerting
enormous pressure either to get rid of
it or to neuter it but to neutral it
means making an exception to the torture
rules for the cia
it seems extraordinary extraordinary
that
an amendment proposed by a distinguished
republican
outlawing the use of torture by
americans should be threatened by the
bush white house with a veto this
remember is a president who has never
yet used the veto
it seems extraordinary that he is
threatening that his first veto could be
against the opposition to torture vito
in favor of torture
makes what we're doing all the more
all the more
you know sharp edged at the moment and
remember
that the pentagon's has so far listed
the deaths of at least 27 prisoners in
american custody
um as confirmed or suspected criminal
homicides
there has been documentation of torture
and abusive treatment at guantanamo and
in iraq and in afghanistan and in what
we now are being told are secret
facilities around the world and this
includes vicious beatings sexual
degradation sodomy near drowning near
asphyxiation hooding stripping detainees
naked subjecting them to extremes of
heat cold noise and light depriving them
of sleep this all falls under
uh international conventions on torture
which say that no one shall be subjected
to torture or to cruel inhuman or
degrading treatment or punishment those
are exactly the words of the mccain
amendment
which president bush is threatening to
veto
the numbers involved are substantial
guantanamo has 700 detainees from 44
countries
and there are maybe 400 prisoners in
afghanistan over 7 000 in iraq and then
arises this bizarre question of the
secret gulag
um we believe it is believed that there
is a an old soviet era compound in
eastern europe according to the
washington post which has now been
reused by the former enemy of the soviet
union the united states
um there is also the question of what is
now being called extraordinary rendition
extraordinary renditions are moments in
which the united states turns over
suspected terrorists to nations such as
syria and egypt those close allies of
this country
which
who are known to use torture as a method
of invest of interrogation
one legal opinion says governmental
authorities surrendering a person to the
authorities of another state that
habitually practiced or practices
torture would themselves become
accomplices of the crime of torture
so when president bush says as he has
been quoted today in the newspapers as
saying that the united states does not
torture
it begins to sound a little hollow when
you look at the evidence that there is
and
to put it simply if the united states
does not torture what possible objection
could there be to an amendment which
stipulates that it will not do so
just in case we think that we're talking
this evening in in abstract in the
abstract i should mention that here in
the audience this evening are two men
who have suffered abuse at u.s detention
facilities
you will probably hear a great deal
about them and from them in the days
ahead because they have they're bringing
an extremely courageous lawsuit against
the secretary of defense and other
high-ranking u.s military officials that
lawsuit
[Applause]
thank you
that that lawsuit is part of a growing
movement to end abusive practices to to
uncover the full extent and human cost
of our of this country's current
detention policies and to hold
responsible uh those responsible for for
violations of these commitment of our
this country's commitments under
international law
and if you are not already involved in
this effort you can start by following
the suggestions of the card that's being
distributed this evening which which
tells you where you can go uh to join uh
your name to this to this
this matter now just to let you know the
format of the evening
um
one writer sadly is not with us grace
paley who we very much regret is not
here because of she's not well
and anyone who knows grace knows that
grace has to be really unwell in order
to cancel um so we wish her we wish her
the very best
um everybody is going to speak um and uh
is going to to present texts which are
not their own they're going to read from
other people's texts which they which
they think to be
relevant and evocative of the of the
issues we're talking about
and we will be again as last time uh
being broadcast live over wbai and other
pacifica stations and affiliates and
also
this is at this moment being streamed
live at kpftx.org
so that's it we're all going to read for
a bit and and i will now
get off the stage and we're going to do
it in alphabetical order
except that i get to finish so you have
to put up with me at the end thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
my name is edward albee i write plays
i want to take us back a little bit at
the beginning and talk about a
man
who was killed
murdered in large part because he was a
writer
after considerable torture
there is both physical and there is
psychological torture
in this case the man was tortured
psychologically
and killed literally
the country of spain
i did my research by the way including
going to spain myself and
finding out some stuff people didn't
want me to know
the country of spain
the time is the
late part of the 1930s
the civil war in spain
is reaching this terrible climax
the fascists
under the direction
of francisco franco
and with the aid
of the
of the germans and their forces
and the help
of the spanish branch of the catholic
church
have overthrown the legal government the
legal liberal government of spain
and are about to take power
the slaughter has been considerable
as many civilians probably
have died as soldiers
on both sides
i would say that the majority
of the
intellectuals and creative people in
spain
have left
they are mostly
leftist politically
and they have gone
to save their careers and indeed
to save their lives
there is one man however
who seems unwilling
to leave spain
he is a writer
and he is indeed a leftist
but he won't leave spain for the very
very simple reason
that he loves spain very much
and he fears
that if he leaves
he will never be allowed to come back
his friends
salvador dali all of the other people
who associates with them before they
leave they say you must leave
you must get out of here for god's sake
you're leftist you're very very far to
the left
your writing
inflames the population plus you're gay
you'd better leave
but he doesn't
he stays
and instead of going to france or italy
or wherever he might have gone
he goes
back home
to granada
to his family's home
on the assumption that he will be safe
once again
where he was safe
when he was very young
unfortunately
this is not the case
someone betrayed him
he is arrested
and he is taken from one prison
to another his family keep following
trying to find him
and the jailers say ah you just missed
him
we took him over there
two miles away
finally
one dawn
he is brought out with 10 or 12 others
put in front of a firing squad
and executed
as his body is lying
face down
on the ground after he's been shot
in his blood
a soldier comes over to him
with a rifle
looks down at the body
points his rifle
directly
at this man's rectum
and shoots him
this dead man
once again
and says
this is what we do to [ __ ] in this
country isn't it
and walks away
and so died at the age of 37
the greatest spanish poet
and playwright
federico
garcia lorca
if we don't learn from history they tell
us
we're bound to repeat it
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
uh my name is paul oster and i'm going
to read from
one of my favorite poets george oppen
it's from a book that he published in
1969 of being numerous which won the
pulitzer prize
and in it there's a
long poem with many parts entitled root
r-o-u-t-e
and this is a prose piece it's from
another time
another kind of craziness another kind
of
horror
but i think applicable nevertheless
george happened to be one of the few
american poets who actually saw
combat in
world war ii
in alsace during the war we found
ourselves on the edge of the battle of
the bulge
the front was inactive
but we were spread so thin that the
situation was eerily precarious
we hardly knew where the next squad was
and it was not in sight a quiet and
deserted hill in front of us
we dug into our farmhouse
pierre adam though he was a journeyman
mason
lived with his wife and his children in
that farmhouse
during the occupations the germans had
declared alsace a part of greater
germany
therefore they had drafted alsatian men
into the german army
many men
learning in their own way that they were
to be called dug a hole
the word became a part of the language
some men were in those holes as long as
two and three years it was necessary
that someone should know where those
holes were
in winter it was impossible for a man to
come out of his hole without leaving
footprints in the snow
while snow was actually falling however
a friend could come to the hole with
food and other help
pierre whom many people trusted
knew where some two dozen of those holes
were
the germans became aware that men were
going into hiding and began to make
reprisals
if the man was young and unmarried they
killed his parents
if the man was married they took his
wife into germany to the army brothels
it was said
they took the children into germany and
it was not certain whether those
children would remember where they came
from
pierre told me this story
men would come to pierre and they would
say i am thinking of making a hole
pierre would say yes
they would say then but if i do they
will kill my parents or they will take
my wife and my children
then pierre would say he told me if you
dig a hole
i will help you
he knew of course what he was telling me
you must try to put yourself into those
times
if one thought he knew anything was that
a man should not join the nazi army
pierre himself learned shortly before
the americans arrived that he was about
to be drafted
he and his wife discussed the children
they thought of tattooing the children's
names and addresses on their chests
so that perhaps they could be found
after the war
but they thought that perhaps the
tattooing would be cut out of the
children they did not finally have to
make that decision as it turned out
but what a conversation between a man
and his wife
there was an escape from that dilemma as
in a way there always is pierre told me
of a man who receiving the notification
that he was report to report to the
german army
called a celebration and farewell at his
home
nothing was said at that party that was
not jovial
they drank and sang
at the proper time the host got on his
bicycle and waved goodbye
the house stood at the top of the hill
and still waving and calling farewells
he rode with great energy and as fast as
he could down the hill
and at the bottom drove into a tree
it must be hard to do
probably easier in an automobile
there is in an automobile a considerable
time during which you cannot change your
mind
riding a bicycle since in those woods it
is impossible that the tree should be a
redwood
it must be necessary to continue aiming
at the tree
right up to the moment of impact
undoubtedly difficult to do
and of course the children had no father
thereafter
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
i'm the most astonished to be here
tonight
i come from that no man's land called
the border
my name is sandra cisneros and i
especially want to thank larry seems for
naming
my name
i'm going to read
from
the book of embraces
by the uruguayan writer
eduardo galliano
and i will read it first in the language
he wrote it
and then i will read it in the
translation by
cedric belfridge
[Music]
folklore
[Music]
the nobodies
fleas dream
of buying themselves a dog
and nobody's
dream of escaping poverty
that one magical day good luck will
suddenly rain down on them we'll rain
down in buckets
but
good luck doesn't rain down yesterday
today
tomorrow
or ever
good luck doesn't even fall in a fine
drizzle no matter how hard the nobody
summon it even if their left hand is
tickling or they begin the new day with
their right foot or start the new year
with a change of brooms
the nobodies
nobody's children owners of nothing the
nobodies the no ones the no-bodied
running like rabbits dying through life
screwed every which way
who are not but
could be
don't speak languages but
dialects
who don't have religions but
superstitions
who don't create art
but handicrafts
who don't have culture
but
folklore
who are not human beings but
human resources
who do not have faces
but arms
who do not have names
but numbers
who do not appear in the history of the
world
but in the police blotter of the local
paper
the nobodies
who are not worth
the bullet
that kills them
we can never underestimate the
willingness of the state
to act out its own massive fantasies
what about the individual
in preparing a script for their play
guantanamo
victoria britain and julian slovo
collected what they call spoken evidence
among the people who spoke to them was a
british woman whose brother was arrested
possibly in pakistan where he was
studying the koran she isn't sure
and then handed over to american
authorities and sent to
guantanamo
is he guilty of a serious crime
or a passport violation or something
else
or nothing at all
the power of the state
is deep enough not only to shape our
waking lives but to reach into our
dreams
often we find ourselves helpless in
dreams but sometimes
dreams are a form of wishful fiction
a response to helplessness
to the condition of not knowing
here is the spoken evidence of janette
bellmore
we might title these remarks dreaming of
richard
everyone in the family has dreams about
richard being released
it's always something positive it's
never something bad in a dream
you just wake up and you just realize
it's a dream
and richard's not here
but the next day i'll say to my parents
i had this dream about richard
and my parents they believe in dreams
but i'm like a dream's a dream it means
nothing
but the dream i've had of richard three
dreams and the last one where i was in
this dream
and richard wasn't in this dream
and i don't know where i am
and the sun is really shining on my face
and i'm complaining that the sun is
burning my face
it's too hot it's too hot
but there's nobody in the dream it's
just me
and the sun is just shining on my face
and i'm saying
it's too hot it's too hot
but in the back of my mind in the dream
i know my brother's home
so i complain it's hot
but i've got this smile on my face as
well i know my brother's home
and one day my brother
i remember being at heathrow airport
and richard was there on his own
in the dream
and i went over to him and he was like
i'm tired
i want to go home and he sort of shoves
me not in an aggressive way but he's
like
i want to go home
i want to go to sleep i'm tired
i want to go to sleep
when i have the dreams it's always warm
so i said to my mom last week
the dream i'm having about richard it's
always warm it's hot
and then i think
maybe if they release him it will be in
the summer
that's what i think
i'm don delilah thanks
i'm
dave eggers i'm going to read from the
blindfolds eye by
diana ortiz ortiz was an american nun
working in a small village in guatemala
when she began to get death threats she
was suspected of aiding the gorillas
this was 1989 a time when thousands of
suspected guerrillas and dissidents were
being abducted and disappeared by the
guatemalan army the strategy of the
guatemalan government was described this
way by the u.s ambassador to guatemala
in a memo to secretary of state james
baker
that the victims are generally unknown
in wider society means a more muted
reaction both locally and abroad
it makes the question why more difficult
to answer and more and many
non-political explanations
for example common crime can plausibly
be put forward to explain the
victimization of a relatively anonymous
person
while the victims are not figures of
wide renown they are well known within
the small groups comprising the left the
bolt from the blue strike against one of
their members causes a ripple of terror
to go through these groups
he wasn't even the most important in our
group they might say if they are willing
to get him no one is safe
this forces many members into hiding or
exile or at least into abandoning
whatever immediate
project the group had
one of ortiz's ortiz's captors who
called himself alejandro spoke spanish
with a distinct american accent and
mentioned his ties to the american
embassy
the cia was working in guatemala at the
time and ortiz was certain that this
alejandro
was a cia agent
orchestrating her torture and that of
the others were being held with her
under his direction ortiz was raped
repeatedly burned with cigarettes and
was forced to stab a fellow detainee
this is the account of her escape
i'm curled up on the cement floor
blindfolded the men are about to rape me
again
hey alejandro come and have some fun one
of them calls
i recognize the name they've mentioned
it before they said alejandro was their
boss
[ __ ] a new voice responds in perfect
unaccented american english then he
switches to spanish which he speaks with
a marked american accent you idiots
leaving her leave her alone she's a
north american i'm
sorry north american and it's all over
the news
alejandro removes my blindfold he is
tall and fair-skinned are you an
american i ask him in english
what do you why do you want to know he
understands me but insists on answering
in spanish bring her clothes he calls he
helps me on with my t-shirt and
sweatshirt and tells jose to go for
water
come on let's get out of here alejandro
leads me down the long hallway i'm sorry
i'm so sorry it was a mistake he says
you must forgive them they had the wrong
person they thought you were veronica
ortiz-hernandez
his hair
is brown curly and dark darker than his
beard in his eyebrows i begin to suspect
he's wearing a wig he has on large dark
glasses what will happen to the other
people in the building i ask don't
concern yourself with them he takes me
up the stairs there are two landings we
go through a door and into a garage in
the garage there is space for about 15
cars he motions me into a gray suzuki
jeep it has a long wavy black horizontal
stripe on the outside near the door
a rabbit's foot hangs from the rear view
mirror i'll take you to a friend at the
u.s embassy who can help you leave the
country
as we pull out of the garage light
dazzles my eyes i make out a couple of
open iron gates we go through them and
turn on turn right onto a main road with
large buildings my attention is is on
alejandro whether i can trust him he's
told me to forget about the other people
in the building the torturer said he was
their boss and they obeyed him he told
them to leave me alone they did he
ordered the other men out of the room
they left he told jose to bring me my
clothes and some water
jose did as he was told alejandro knows
i've seen the tortures or torturers
faces and his face too he's taking me to
kill me
a tape of classical music is playing it
stops and he turns it over
on his left finger a wide gold wedding
band gleams in the light the sun is low
it's twilight or early morning i guess i
sit forward to protect my back my ribs
my burns are throbbing
look you have to forgive those guys
dianida they made a mistake
they didn't make a mistake the death
threats were addressed to me not to
veronica ortiz
we tried to warn you with the threats he
says to prevent this but you wouldn't
leave
i stayed because i have a commitment to
the people i said
i have a commitment to the people too he
said to liberate them from communist
communism
your commitment is different because you
don't have respect for human life i say
all this time i've been speaking spanish
he's been responding in spanish with
grammar worse than mine beginner
mistakes like using a feminine article
with a masculine noun
but now he switches to english well you
know we have the photos of you and the
videos those could be embarrassing
my breath stops he is american and the
torturers have told him about what i did
what they filmed me doing now he's
threatening me with blackmail
does that mean he won't kill me or will
he change his mind even if i promise to
keep quiet is he just playing with me
i look around the traffic is picked up
now i catch sight of a sign zone five
there is only one place in guatemala
with with zone signs and that's the
capital i'm in zone five of guatemala
city up ahead is a red light alejandra
slows and soon we're at a dead
standstill i open my door and i jump
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
my name is martinez pada
i will read a poem by raul surita
surita is a major chilean poet
he was detained and tortured
aboard a navy ship in balbara iso
after the 1973 coup in chile
this poem was published
in 1982
and it is a work of the political
imagination
it envisions a day
of liberation in chile
almost a decade before general pinochet
was ousted from power
and if the people of chile
could get their democracy back after 17
years of dictatorship
we can get our democracy back too
[Applause]
[Music]
this prophetic poem
is number nine from the series called
pastoral of chile
i will read it first in spanish and then
in the english translation
by jack
schmidt
it is
with laughter
for she and i have found one another
shout
fieldstones and briars because for our
love's sake the city jails are
collapsing the bars are breaking and
even the padlocks have given way
bursting in the entryways so laugh
laugh because we found one another
fall head over heels in the meadows she
and i may we love one another forever
and in the name of our love let even the
steel-toed boots that kicked us beloved
and those who mocking us said do a
little dance for us
and put out their cigarettes and our
arms so we would dance for them for our
love's sake for that alone let them now
dance adorning the fields like
sunflowers
then behold this country turned green so
that father and son
wife and husband may be blessed so that
even the lion and lioness may be blessed
and then say who can extinguish this
love
neither oceans nor rivers will
extinguish or smother it
so
[Music]
[Music]
i'm philip gravich
i'm going to read tonight the words of a
midwestern republican
to remind us all that sometimes to stand
against
all that we oppose most is done out of
an absolutely passionate belief
in good
in the possibilities of government
um since i'm standing at the lincoln
podium tonight here
this is uh abraham lincoln's address
before the young men's lyceum of
springfield illinois on january 27 1838
a fairly early speech and the backdrop
was that there had been a great deal i
had to
cut a lot from the speech to fit it into
at the time um uh he uh
the backdrop was that there was a great
deal of vigilantism in the country um
two particularly in major incidents were
much in the tabloids and the papers the
lynching
of a murderer a mulatto murderer
in saint louis
and in mississippi a series of lynchings
that began as he put it with the hanging
of gamblers and from gamblers to negros
from negros to white citizens and from
these to strangers till dead men were
seen literally dangling from the boughs
of trees upon every roadside and in
numbers almost sufficient to rival the
native spanish moss of the country as a
drapery of the forest
is abraham lincoln in springfield
illinois
as a subject for the remarks of the
evening the perpetuation of our
political institutions is selected
in the great journal of things happening
under the sun we the american people
find ourselves in the peaceful
possession of the fairest portion of the
earth as regards extent of territory
fertility of soil and solubility of
climate
we find ourselves under the government
of a system of political institutions
conducing more essentially to the ends
of civil and religious liberty than any
of which the history of former times
tells us
we
when mounting the stage of existence
found ourselves the legal inheritors of
these fundamental blessings we toiled
not in the acquirement or establishment
of them their legacy bequeathed us by a
once-hearty brave and patriotic but now
lamented and departed race of ancestors
theirs was the task and nobody they
performed it to possess themselves and
through themselves us of this goodly
land and to apprear upon its hills and
its valleys a political evidence of
liberty and equal rights tis ours only
to transmit these to the latest
generation
how then shall we perform this task
at what point shall we expect the
approach of danger
by what means shall we fortify against
it
shall we expect some transatlantic
military giant to step the ocean and
crush us at a blow
never
all the armies of europe asia and africa
combined with all the treasure of the
earth our own accepted in their military
chest with a bonaparte for a commander
could not by force take a drink from the
ohio or make a track on the blue ridge
in a trial of a thousand years
at what point then is the approach of
danger to be expected
i answer
if it ever reach us
it must spring up amongst us
it cannot come from abroad
if destruction be our lot we must
ourselves be its author and finisher
as a nation of free men we must live
through all time or die by suicide
i hope i'm over weary but if i'm not
there is even now something of illoma
amongst us i mean the increasing
disregard for law which pervades the
country the growing disposition to
substitute the wild and furious passions
in lieu of the sober judgment of courts
and worse than savage mobs for the
executive ministers of justice
when making men take it in their heads
today to hang gamblers or burn murderers
they should recollect that in the
confusion usually attending such
transactions they will be as likely to
hang or burn someone who is neither a
gambler nor a murderer as one who is
and that acting upon the example they
set the mob of tomorrow may and probably
will hang or burn some of them by the
very same mistake
but all this even is not the full extent
of the evil by such examples
by instances of the perpetrators of such
acts going unpunished the lawless and
spirit are encouraged to become lawless
in practice and having been used to no
restraint but dread of punishment
they thus become absolutely unrestrained
having ever regarded government as their
deadliest pain they make a jubilee of
the suspension of its operations and
pray for nothing so much as its total
annihilation but it may be asked why
supposed danger to our political
institutions have we not preserved them
for more than 50 years and why may we
not for 50 times as long
we hope there is no sufficient reason
but to conclude that no danger may ever
arise would itself be extremely
dangerous
that our government should have
maintained been maintained in its
original form from its establishment
until now is not much to be wondered at
it had many props to support it through
that period which now were decayed and
crumbled away
through that period it was felt by all
to be an undecided experiment
now
it is understood to be a successful one
then all that sought celebrity and fame
and distinction expected to find them in
the success of that experiment there all
was staked upon it their destiny was
inseparably linked with it their
ambition aspired to display before an
admiring world a practical demonstration
of the truth of a proposition which had
hitherto been considered at best no
better than problematical namely the
capability of a people to govern
themselves
if they succeeded they were to be
immortalized their names were to be
transferred to counties and cities and
rivers and mountains and to be revered
in song and toasted through all time
if they failed they were to be called
knaves and fools and fanatics for a
fleeting hour than to sink and be
forgotten
they succeeded
the experiment is successful and
thousands have won their deathless names
in making it so
but the game is caught
and i believe it is true that with the
catching ends the pleasure of the chase
this field of glory is harvested and the
crop is already appropriated
but new reapers will arise and they too
will seek a field
it is to deny what the history of the
world tells us is true to suppose that
men of ambition and talents will not
continue to spring up amongst us
and when they do
they will as naturally seek the
gratification of their ruling passion as
others have so done before them
the question then is can that
gratification be found in supporting and
maintaining an edifice that has been
erected by others
most certainly it cannot
many great and good men sufficiently
qualified for any task they should
undertake may ever be found
whose ambition would inspire aspire to
nothing beyond a seat in congress
a gubernatorial
or a presidential chair
but such belong not to the family of the
lion or the tribe of the eagle
what
thank you these places would satisfy an
alexander a caesar and napoleon
never
towering genius disdains a beaten path
it seeks regions hitherto unexplored it
sees no distinction in adding story to
story upon the monuments of fame erected
to the memory of others it denies that
it is glory enough to serve under any
chief it scorns to tread in the
footsteps of any predecessor however
illustrious it thirsts and burns for
distinction and if possible it will have
it
whether at the expense of emancipating
slaves
or enslaving free men
it will require the people to be united
with each other attached to the
government and laws and generally
intelligent to successfully frustrate
such designs
here then is a probable case highly
dangerous and such a one as could not
have well existed heretofore
passion has helped us but can do so no
more
it will be in future our enemy
reason
cold calculating on impassioned reason
must furnish all the materials for our
future support and defense let those
materials be molded into general
intelligence
sound morality and in particular a
reference for the constitution and laws
upon these let the proud fabric of
freedom rest as the rock of its basis
and this truly has been and as has been
said of the only greater institution
the gates of hell shall not prevail
against it
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
my name is jessica hagedorn
i'll be reading from a document called
exhibit d
i declare under penalty of perjury of
the laws of the united states
that the following is true and correct
i am a citizen of the state of kuwait
am over 18 years of age and have never
been charged or convicted of any crime
i have been incarcerated at guantanamo
for more than three and a half years
i have never fought against the united
states and i am totally innocent of any
wrongdoing
since august 4th 2005
i have refused voluntarily to eat drink
or accept medicine
after about three weeks i collapsed on
the floor and couldn't stand up and they
put me on an iv
at the beginning of september guards
took me to the hospital
they put me on an orange board on my
back for six hours with my arms strapped
on my side
they said
we will put a feeding tube in you
i refused they strapped me down on the
bed and forced a tube through my nose
twice the tube came out through my mouth
i spit blood
the doctors told me that they had a
court order authorizing them to do this
my attorney informed me that there was
no court order
i then confronted the doctors and told
them they had lied about having a court
order
after that i tore the tubes out
the guards then came and took me from my
cell to the clinic
they tied me up so that i could not move
and then force the tubes back in me
my right foot was hurt when they did
this it is in a cast and i need to use a
walker to walk
i have continued to lose weight despite
the force feeding
i have attached charts i took from the
clinic showing that my weight has
continued to drop
and that i have gone from 200 pounds to
132 pounds it is even lower than that
now but i no longer will stand on the
scale to allow them to weigh me
since they have been force-feeding me
here i have continuously experienced
nausea diarrhea and vomiting
to monitor my health a nurse comes to my
cell once a week to weigh me take my
blood pressure take a blood sample as
mentioned i will no longer stand on the
scale this is one thing they cannot
force me to do
they do force me to give a blood sample
the blood samples are taken by a nurse
or core man and they are inexperienced
and it is painful
at the beginning when they force fed me
they used a tube with a size called 12
french
then after two or three days they pulled
it out and forced in
a much larger tube with a size called 18
french
then they would take it out after the
feeding and then force it back in again
before the next feeding sometimes they
would reinsert the old tube without
sterilizing it
when i complained the doctor told me
they did not have adequate medical
equipment
for the last approximately three weeks
they have used smaller tubes and they do
not take it out after each feeding and
reinsert it before the next
i understand now that it is useless for
me to resist
and the guards will only tie me up and
will force feed me no matter what i want
i believe that now there are between 20
and 25 people being force-fed at
guantanamo i swear that the above is
true and correct
abdulaziz al-shammari october 10 2005.
dear jessica
november 7th 2005.
mr al-shammari a teacher went to
afghanistan in the fall of 2001 on a
charitable mission he was turned over to
and then detained by the u.s for four
years
mr al-shamari was finally released last
friday november 4th and returned to
kuwait pursuant to an agreement
negotiated between the governments of
kuwait and the united states
he is the father of two children
our firm represents all kuwaiti
detainees at guantanamo initially this
was 12 detainees and now six of those
have been repatriated including mr
shimari
we petitioned the courts for a writ of
habeas corpus on behalf of the detainees
and the name of our case is al oda
versus united states
a year and a half ago our case was
presented to the supreme court along
with rasul versus bush
the supreme court held that the habeas
statute does confer the right of
judicial review on the detainees held at
guantanamo they have a right to have
their petitions heard by the district
courts and their cases considered
however on remand the government again
moved to dismiss
stating that although they may have a
right to present a petition they have no
rights that can be enforced by the
courts
although the government lost this
argument at this district court level
they appealed and we are currently
awaiting for the decision of the u.s
court of appeals for the district of
columbia in the meantime the detainees
continue to be held without any hearing
in terrible conditions confined to tiny
cells with little or no exercise
reading material or opportunity to
interact with others
in the past few months many of the
detainees have gone on hunger strikes to
protest their condition namely the lack
of a fair trial the deprivation of
decent food water and living conditions
and the mistreatment that has
characterized their stay at guantanamo
mr al shamaari was one of those
i hope that's helpful
let me know if you have any questions
amanda schaefer associate sherman in
sterling washington d.c
thank you
[Music]
my name is heidi chulawitz
um
it's my thinking that if hannah arendt
had decided after the eichmann trial
to try her hand at a work of blackley
comic short fiction
she might have come up with something
like donald barthel mays some of us had
been threatening our friend colby
some of us have been threatening our
friend colby for a long time because of
the way he had been behaving
and now he'd gone too far so we decided
to hang him
colby argued that just because he had
gone too far he did not deny that he had
gone too far did not mean that he should
not that he should be subjected to
hanging going too far he said was
something everybody did sometimes we
didn't pay much attention to this
argument we asked him what sort of music
he would like played at the hanging
the next item of business was the gibbet
none of us knew too much about gibbet
design but tomas who is an architect
said he'd look it up in old books and
draw the plans
the important thing as far as he
recollected
was that the trapdoor functioned
properly
he said that just roughly counting labor
and materials it shouldn't run us more
than four hundred dollars good god
howard said he said what was tomas
figuring on rosewood
no just a good grain of pine tama said
victor asked if unpainted pine wouldn't
look kind of raw and tomas replied that
he thought it could be stained a dark
walnut without too much trouble
i said that although i thought the whole
thing ought to be done really well and i
i also thought 400 for a gibbet on top
of the expense of the drinks invitations
musicians and everything was a bit steep
and why didn't we just use a tree a nice
looking oak or something i pointed out
that it was going to be a june hanging
the trees would be in glorious leaf and
that not only would a tree add a kind of
natural feeling but it was also strictly
traditional especially in the west
then the question of the hangman came up
paul said do we really need a hangman
because if we used a tree the news could
be adjusted to the appropriate level and
colby could just jump off something a
chair or stool or something besides paul
said he very much doubted if there were
any freelance hangman wandering the
country now that capital punishment had
been done away with absolutely
temporarily and that we'd probably have
to fly one in from england or spain or
one of the south american countries and
even if we did how would we know in
advance that the man was a professional
real hangman and not some money-hungry
amateur who might bungle the job and
shame us all in front of everybody
we all agreed
that kobe should just jump off something
and that a chair was not what he should
jump off of because that would look we
felt extremely tacky some old kitchen
chair sitting out there under our
beautiful tree
tama tomas who is quite modern in
outlook and not afraid of innovation
proposed that colby be standing on a
large rubber ball 10 feet in diameter
this he said would afford a sufficient
drop and would also roll out of the way
if colby suddenly changed his mind after
jumping
men have been known to get a little
resolute at times like that and the
10-foot rubber ball which could probably
be fabricated rather cheaply would
ensure a bang-up production right down
to the wire
at the mention of wire hank who had been
silent all this time suddenly spoke up
and said he wondered if it wouldn't be
better if we use wire instead of rope
more efficient and in the end kinder to
colby he suggested
colby began looking a little green and i
didn't blame him because there was
something extremely distasteful and
thinking about being hanged with wire
instead of rope it gives you a sort of
revulsion when you think about it so i
hastily said that wire was out of the
question because it would injure the
tree
cut into the branch it was tied to when
colby's full weight hit it and that in
these days of increased respect for the
environment we didn't want to do that
did we
colby gave me a grateful look and the
meeting broke up
everything went off very smoothly on the
day of the event the music colby finally
picked was standard stuff and it was
played very well by howard and his boys
it didn't rain and the event was well
attended and we didn't run out of scotch
or anything
the 10-foot rubber ball had been painted
a deep green and blended in well with
the bucolic setting the two things i
remember best about the whole episode
are the grateful look colby gave me when
i said what i said about the wire and
the fact that nobody
has ever gone too far again
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
i'm nicole krauss
um
i'm going to read you something from
someone called jean emery
who
basically i came across for the first
time reading uh wg zebald and it was a
passage that i've been unable to forget
since then so i've gone back and i'm
going to read you from
um
amury's book which is called at the
mines limits
he was
someone who fought in the french
resistance was captured and tortured by
the nazis and as a political prisoner
and then ultimately discovered to be a
jew and sent to auschwitz
this was written about 20 years after
the experience
in the bunker there hung from the
vaulted ceiling a chain that above ran
into a roll
at its bottom end it bore a heavy
broadly curved iron hook i was led to
the instrument
though gripped into the shackle that
held my hands together behind my back
then i raised with the chain until i
hung about a meter over the floor
in such a position or rather when
hanging this way
with your hands behind your back
for a short time you can hold at a half
oblique through muscular force
during these few minutes when you are
already expending your utmost strength
when sweat has already appeared in your
forehead and lips
and you are breathing in gasps you will
not answer any questions
accomplices
addresses meeting places you hardly hear
it
all your life is gathered in a single
limited area of the body the shoulder
joints and it does not react
for it exhausts itself completely in the
expenditure of energy
but this cannot last long
even with people who have a strong
physical constitution
as for me i had to give up rather
quickly
and now there was a crackling and
splintering in my shoulders that my body
has not forgotten until this hour
the balls sprang from their sockets
my own body weight caused luxation
i fell into a void and now hung by my
dislocated arms which had been torn high
from behind and were now twisted over my
head
torture from latin for care to twist
what visual instruction and etymology
it would be totally
senseless to try and describe here the
pain that was inflicted on me
was it like a red hot iron in my
shoulders and was another like a dull
wooden stake that had been driven into
the back of my head
one comparison would only stand for the
other and in the end we would be hoaxed
by turn on the hopeless merry-go-round
of figurative speech
the pain was what it was
beyond that there is nothing to say
qualities of a feeling are as
incomparable as they are indescribable
they mark the limit of the capacity of
language to communicate
if someone wanted to impart his physical
pain he would be forced to inflict it
and thereby become a torturer himself
it was over for a while
it still is not over
22 years later i am still dangling over
the ground by dislocated arms
if from the experience of torture any
knowledge at all remains that goes
beyond the plain nightmarish
it is that of a great amazement and
foreignness in the world that cannot be
compensated by any sort of subsequent
human communication
amazed the tortured person experienced
that in this world there can be the
other as absolute sovereign and
sovereignty revealed itself as a power
to inflict suffering and to destroy
the dominion of the torture over his
victim has nothing in common with the
power exercised on the basis of social
contracts as we know it
the power of the torture under which the
tortured moans as nothing other than the
triumph of the survivor over the one who
has plunged from the world into agony
and death
astonishment at the existence of the
other
as he
boundlessly asserts himself through
torture and astonishment at what one can
become oneself
the tortured person never ceases to be
amazed that all of those things one may
according to inclination call his soul
or his mind or his consciousness or his
identity
are destroyed when there is that
crackling and splintering
in his shoulder joints
that life is fragile as a truism he had
always known
and that it can be ended as shakespeare
says with a little pin
but only through torture did he learn
that a living person can be transformed
so thoroughly into flesh and by that
while still alive be partly made into a
prey of death
whoever has succumbed to torture can no
longer feel at home in the world
the shame of destruction cannot be
erased
trust in the world
which already collapsed in part at the
first blow
but in the end under torture fully will
not be regained
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hi i'm rick moody
i'm reading from
curzio malaparta's memoir
the skin which is about uh
american occupation of naples
at the end of the second world war
and i stress memoir you won't believe it
after you hear this scene but
it's actually recounted in someone
else's book too so there's there's
reason to believe it's true
[Music]
in the whole of naples
it was impossible to find a fish bone
let alone a fish
there was not a sardine not a hog fish
not a lobster a mullet or a cuttlefish
there was nothing
consequently when general cork gave a
dinner in honor of some
high allied officer like field marshal
alexander
or some important politician
or some commission of american senators
he was in the habit of having the fish
for his table
caught in the naples aquarium
which apart from that at munich is
perhaps the most important aquarium in
europe
it followed that the fish served at
general cork's dinners
were always very fresh
and of a rare species
at the dinner which he had given in
honor of general eisenhower
we had eaten the famous giant octopus
presented to the naples aquarium
by emperor william two of germany
the celebrated japanese fish known as
dragons
a gift from the emperor hirohito of
japan
have been sacrificed on general cork's
table in honor of a party of senators
the enormous mouths of those monstrous
fish their yellow gills their black and
scarlet fins which resembled the wings
of a bat
their green and gold tails and their
heads bristling with prickles and
crested like the helmet of achilles had
profoundly depressed the spirits of the
senators who are already preoccupied
with the progress of the war against
japan
but general cork who in addition to his
military virtues
possessed the qualities of a perfect
diplomat
had restored his guests morale by
entoning johnny gotta zero
the famous song of the american airmen
in the pacific
and they had all sung its chorus
thus one by one all the rarest and most
famous fish in the aquarium
have been sacrificed to general cork's
mental cruelty
including even the heroic swordfish a
gift from mussolini which had been
served steamed with a border
of boiled potatoes
and the strikingly beautiful tuni a gift
from his majesty
king victor emmanuel
iii
but one fine day the supply of fish in
the aquarium ran out
there only remained the famous siren a
very rare example of that species of
cyrenoids which because of their almost
human form gave rise to the ancient
legend about the sirens
and a few wonderful stems of coral
general cork who had the praiseworthy
habit of concerning himself personally
with the smallest details had asked the
major domo
what kind of fish it would be possible
to catch in the aquarium for the dinner
he was giving in honor of a mrs flatt
there's very little left major domo had
replied only a siren and a few stems of
coral
is it a good fish the siren
excellent the major domo had replied
without batting an eyelid
and coral general cork asked is it good
to eat
no not coral it's a little indigestible
well then no coral
we can use it as a border the major domo
had suggested imperturbally
imperturbably that's fine
and the major domo had written on the
menu
siren mayonnaise with a border of coral
and now
pale faced and dome with surprise and
horror
we were all looking at that poor dead
child
as she lay open-eyed on the silver tray
on a bed of green lettuce leaves
encircled by a wreath of pink coral
stems
walking along the miserable alleys of
naples one often catches a glimpse
through the open door of some basso
of a dead man lying on a bed encircled
by wreath of flowers
and it's not unusual to see
the corpse of a little girl
but i have never seen the corpse of a
little girl
encircled by a wreath of coral
i looked at that poor boiled child and i
trembled inwardly
with pity and pride
a wonderful country italy i thought
what other people in the world can
permit itself the luxury of offering
siren mayonnaise with a border a border
of coral to a foreign army that has
destroyed and invaded its country
it was worth losing the war just to see
those american officers and that proud
american woman sitting pale and horror
stricken around the table of an american
general on which in a silver tray
reposed the body of a siren
a sea
goddess
disgusting exclaimed mrs flatt covering
her eyes with her hands
yes i mean uh
yes
stammered general cork pale and
trembling take it away take that
horrible thing away cried mrs flatt
why i said it's an excellent fish
but there must be some mistake please
forgive me there must be some mistake
forgive me stammered poor general cork
with a whale of distress i assure you
it's an excellent fish i said but we
can't eat that
that girl
colonel elliot it isn't a girl i said
it's a fish
general said mrs flatt in a stern voice
i hope you won't force me to eat that
that poor girl but it's a fish said
general cork it's a first-rate fish
malaparta says it's excellent he knows
i haven't come to europe to be forced to
eat human flesh by her friend said mrs
flatt her voice trembling with
indignation let's leave it to these
barbarous italians to eat children at
dinner i refuse
i'm an honest american woman i won't eat
italian children
i'm sorry i'm terribly sorry said
general cork mopping his brow which was
dripping with perspiration but in naples
everyone eats this species of child i
mean the species of fish
isn't it true malaparta that this
species of child of fish is is excellent
it's an excellent fish i replied and
what does it matter if it looks like a
child it's a fish
in europe a fish doesn't have to look
like a fish
nor in america said general cork glad to
find at last someone who would stick up
for him what cried mrs flatt in europe i
said fish at least are free
no one says that a fish mustn't look
like a what shall i say a man or a child
or a woman
and this is a fish even if
well anyhow i added what did you what
did you expect to eat when you came to
italy the corpse of mussolini
ha ha ha that's very funny roar general
cork but his laughter was too shrill to
be genuine ha ha ha and all the others
joined in their laughter a strangely
conflicting blend of dismay doubt and
merriment
i have never loved the americans i shall
never love them in the way that i did
that evening as i sat at that table
confronted by that horrible fish
take it away
shouted general cork suddenly to the
major domo pointing to the siren take
that thing away
general
wait a moment said colonel brown the
chaplain attending the general
headquarters
we must bury that
that poor
kid what exclaimed mrs flatt we must
bury this
this
said the chaplain do you mean said
general cork yes i mean barry said the
chaplain but it's a fish said general
cork it may be a fish said the chaplain
but it looks more like a little girl
allow me to insist it's our duty to bury
this little girl i mean this fish we are
christians are we not
i have my doubts said mrs flatt gazing
at general cork with an expression of
contempt
yes i suppose replied general cork we
must bury it said colonel brown
all right said general court but where
should we bury it i would say throw it
on the ash heap that seems the simplest
thing
we could bury it in the garden said the
chaplain
that's a good idea said general cork his
face clearing we can bury it in the
garden and turning to the major domo he
added
please go and bury this
this thing this fish in the garden
yes said the major domo bowing and
meanwhile the footmen lifted the
gleaming solid silver beer on which the
poor dead siren lay
and put it on the stretcher
i said bury it said general cork i for i
forbid you to eat it in the kitchen
yes general said the major domo but it's
such a pity it's a lovely fish
we don't know for certain that it is a
fish said general i forbid you to eat it
the major domo bowed the footman set off
in the direction of the door
carrying the gleaming silver beer on the
stretcher
and we all followed that strange funeral
procession
with our sad eyes
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
everything
[Music]
hello
i'm walter mosley
um
i'm going to read a poem
from a collection called in case of fire
in a foreign land by ariel dorfman
came out in 2002
the poem is called hope
the reason the reason i'm i'm reading uh
this poem it seems to me
that the the biggest issue that
that we have with terror is
what our acceptance
of torture
has made us into and i think i think
that uh
ariel's poem
talks about that it's called hope
it's very short
my son has been missing since may 8 of
last year
they took him
just for a few hours they said just
for some routine questioning
after the car left the car with no
license plate
we couldn't
find out anything else about him
but now things have changed
we heard from a companiero
who just got out that five months later
they were torturing him in via grimaldi
at the end of september they were
questioning him in the red house that
once belonged to the grimaldis
they say they recognized his voice
his screams they say
somebody
tell me frankly
what what times are these what
kind of world what country
what i'm asking is
how can it be
that a father's joy
a mother's joy
is knowing
that they
that they are still torturing their son
which means that he was alive five
months later and our greatest hope
will be to find out
next year that they're still torturing
him
eight months later
and he may
might
could
still be alive
[Applause]
so
[Music]
good evening
my name is emma roberte i'm from
barcelona and i'm here today to share my
feelings with all of you with regard to
the guantanamo prison camp
two years ago the department of defense
invited a group of journalists to visit
guantanamo for a week
what i found there was a military base
full of contrasts
guantanamo has a golf course
a cinema
a mcdonald's
and a primary school
but since early 2002 it has also been a
prison for 700 men who have been denied
the status of prisoner of war as granted
by international law
as a lawyer and journalist
guantanamo was a shock to me
the prisoners do not know why they have
been detained
nor when they will be judged
nor if they will see their families
again
they are considered
enemy combatants
the truth is we do not know if the
prisoners of guantanamo are guilty or
innocent
some could be guilty
but in any case they have the right to a
core hearing that will demonstrate their
guilt or innocence
one week after my visit to guantanamo a
group of the prisoners parents came on
to this very stage at cooper union
to denounce the situation suffered by
their sons
i was in the audience
as you are today
the visit of those parents to new york
and my visit to guantanamo bay
led me to write a book denouncing the
legal vacuum
in which more than 700 prisoners
of 40 different nationalities find
themselves
tonight
two years later
the situation of the prisoners has not
improved
guantanamo will be written down in
history as one of the darkest and
saddest episodes in universal human
rights
our silence
the silence of our governments
makes us all accomplish us
let me ask you this
in the face of guantanamo
how can we be sure
that one day
our families and friends will not be
deprived of the rights as well
let me share with you a poem by jose
gustingo tischolo
a catalan poet a member of a group known
as the school of barcelona
gortiszolo's mother was a victim of the
spanish civil war
for this reason i would like to dedicate
this poem to the victims of all wars
families volunteers soldiers and
journalists as well
nadia stasolo
no one is alone
translated into english by maria newman
no one is alone
at this very moment a man is suffering
a man tortured just for his love of
liberty
do not know where he lives
what language he speaks
what his name is
but at this very moment
as your eyes read my little poem
that man exists cries out
and you can hear him howl like a trapped
animal
as he bites his lips so as not to betray
his friends
can you hear him
a man alone in shackles cries out
he exists somewhere
alone i say
don't you feel as i do
how the pain in his body is echoed in
your body
doesn't your blood spill too
with each blind stroke
no one is alone
now
at this very moment they are holding the
two of us in shackles as well thank you
[Music]
[Music]
my name's martha southgate
before i read i'd like to urge everyone
to go beyond their presence here and
take at least a small action to work
against our government's current
cavalier
attitude towards torture
you can find information on the penn
website or at amnesty international's
website
i think even taking a small action that
says not in our name is significant
i'd also like to take a minute to thank
three people who helped me prepare for
this evening my friends charles baxter
jessica greenbaum and diana ayton
shanker the poem i'm going to read is
was inspired by events in el salvador
but it has terrifying resonance for us
here today
it's called the colonel and it's in the
collection the country between us by
carolyn forshay
what you've heard is true
i was in his house
his wife carried a tray of coffee and
sugar
his daughter filed her his daughter
filed her nails
his son went out for the night
there were daily papers pet dogs a
pistol on the cushion beside him
the moon swung bare on its black cord
over the house
on the television was a cop show
it wasn't english
broken bottles were embedded in the
walls around the house to scoop the
kneecaps from a man's legs
or cut his hands to lace
on the windows there were gratings like
those in liquor stores
we had dinner rack of lamb good wine a
gold bell was on the table for calling
the maid
the maid brought green mangoes salt a
type of bread
i was asked how i enjoyed the country
there was a brief commercial in spanish
his wife took everything away
there was some talk then of how
difficult it had become to govern
the parrot said hello on the terrace
the colonel told it to shut up and
pushed himself from the table
my friend said to me with his eyes say
nothing
the colonel returned with a sack used to
bring groceries home he spilled many
human ears on the table
they were like dried peach halves
there is no other way to say this
he took one of them in his hands shook
it in our faces dropped it into a water
glass
it came alive there
i'm tired of fooling around he said
as for the rights of anyone
tell your people they can go [ __ ]
themselves
he swept the ears to the floor with his
arm and held the last of the wine in the
air
something for your poetry no he said
some of the ears on the floor caught
this scrap of his voice
some of the ears on the floor were
pressed to the ground
[Applause]
[Music]
howdy i'm a colson whitehead and i'm
going to read a section from
jose saramago's blindness
i was thinking of this book a lot of the
first week of september when we were
getting the first images and news from
new orleans
about the stadium and the convention
center
and
i think it also fits with tonight's
topic so
um
an epidemic of blindness has come across
the city the blind are being detained in
a um
abandoned hospital
um
soldiers patrol the perimeter to keep
the blind from going out and no one
wants to deal with them they don't get
infected
this section is the occasion of a food
drop they haven't eaten in days
and
they're about to try and get some food
and no one knows that in a couple days
and weeks
both the powerful and the weak will be
blind
as if it had been waiting all this time
for a code word some cue an open sesame
the voice finally came over the
loudspeaker
attention attention the internees may
come and collect their food
but be careful
if anyone gets too close to the gate
they will receive a preliminary warning
and unless they turn back immediately
the second warning will be a bullet
the blind internees
advanced slowly some more confident
toward the right where they thought they
would find the door
the others less sure of their ability to
get their bearings preferred to slide
along the wall
in this way there was no possibility of
mistaking the way when they reached the
corner all they had to do was follow the
wall at a right angle and and there they
would find the door
the hector the hectoring voice over the
loudspeaker impatiently repeated the
summons
the change of tone unmistakable even for
those who had no reason to be suspicious
terrified the blind internees
one of them declared i'm not budging
from here what they want to do is catch
us outside and then kill us all
i'm not moving either said another nor
me chipped in a third
they were frozen to the spot undecided
someone to go but fear was getting the
better of all of them
the voice came again
unless within the next three minutes
someone appears to collect the
containers we shall take them away
this threat failed to overcome their
fear only pushed it to the innermost
caverns of their mind
like hunted animals that await an
opportunity to attack
each one trying to hide behind the other
the blind internees moved fearfully out
onto the landing at the top of the steps
they could not see that the containers
were not alongside the guide rope where
they expected to find them
for they were not to know that that the
soldiers out of fear of being
contaminated
had refused to go anywhere near the rope
which the blind internees were holding
on
the food containers were stacked up
together more or less at the spot where
the doctor's wife had collected the
spade earlier that day
come forward come forward order the
sergeant in some confusion the blind
internees tried to get into a line so as
to advance in an orderly fashion but the
sergeant bellowed at them you won't find
the containers there let go of the rope
let go of it
move over to the right your right your
right fools you don't need eyes to know
which side you have on your right hand
the warning was given just in time some
of the blind internees who were
punctilious in these matters had
interpreted the order literally
if it was on the right logically that
would mean the right of the person
speaking therefore they had they were
trying to pass under the rope to go and
search the containers which were god
knows where
in different circumstances this
grotesque spectacle would have caused
the most restrained spectator to burst
into howls of laughter
it was too funny for words some of the
blind internees advancing on all fours
their faces practically touching the
ground as if they were pigs one arm
outstretched in midair while others
perhaps afraid that the white space
without a roof to protect them would
swallow them up clung desperately to
their rope and listened attentively
expecting to hear at any moment that
first exclamation of triumph once the
containers were
discovered the soldiers with the
soldiers would have liked to aim their
weapons and without compunction shoot
down those imbeciles moving before their
eyes like lame crabs waving their
unsteady pincers in search of their
missing leg
they knew what had been said in the
barracks that morning by the regimental
commander that the problem that the
problem of these blind internees could
be resolved only by physically wiping
out the lot of them
those already there and those still to
come without any phony humanitarian
considerations his very words just as
one amputates a gangrenous limb
in order to save the rest of the body
the rabies of a dead dog he said to
illustrate the point is cured by nature
for some of the soldiers less sensitive
to the beauties of figurative language
it was difficult to understand what a
dog with rabies had to do with the blind
but the word of a regimental commander
once again figuratively speaking is
worth its weight in gold
no man rises to so high a rank in the
army without being right in everything
he thinks
says and does thanks
[Applause]
[Music]
it falls to me to thank the 15
readers this evening
[Music]
and to mention in conclusion
the word vietnam
there is a sense in which what is
happening in iraq is not like vietnam
the iraqis
are far more divided than the vietnamese
were
in this country there is no draft
and in vietnam
it was
american soldiers
imprisoned by the north vietnamese
who were subjected to cruel inhuman and
degrading treatment in iraq
the jailers are american
so there are differences
serious differences and yet
and yet
these are two or three very short
passages from michael here's dispatches
the ground was always in play always
being swept under the ground was his
above it was ours we had the air we
could get up in it but not disappear
into it we could run but we couldn't
hide and he could do each so well that
sometimes it looked like he was doing
them both at once while our finder just
went limp
all the same one place or other it was
always going on rock around the clock we
had the days and he had the knights
you could be in the most protected space
in vietnam and still know that your
safety was provisional that early death
blindness loss of legs arms or balls
major and lasting disfigurement the
whole rotten deal could come in on the
freaky flukey as easily as in the
so-called expected ways you heard so
many of those stories it was a wonder
anyone was left alive to die in
firefights and water rocket attacks
after a few weeks when the nickel had
jarred loose and dropped and i saw that
everyone around me was carrying a gun i
also saw that any one of them could go
off at any time putting you where it
wouldn't matter where it had been an
accident or not the roads were mined the
trails were booby-trapped satchel
charges and grenades blew up jeeps and
movie theaters the vc got work inside
all the camps as shoeshine boys and
laundresses and honey dippers they'd
start your fatigues and burn your [ __ ]
and then go home and mortar your area
saigon and cholan and da nang held such
hostile vibes that you felt you were
being dry sniped every time someone
looked at you and choppers fell out of
the sky like fat poisoned birds a
hundred times a day after a while i
couldn't get on one without thinking
that i must be out of my [ __ ] mind
sitting in saigon was like sitting
inside the folded petals of a poisonous
flower the poison history [ __ ] in its
roots no matter how far back you wanted
to run your trace saigon was the only
place left with a continuity that
someone as far outside as i was could
recognize hui and da nang were like
remote closed societies mute and
intractable villages even large ones
were fragile a village could disappear
in an afternoon and the countryside was
either blasted blasted over cold and
dead or already back in charles's hands
saigon remained the repository and the
arena it breathed history expelled it
like toxin [ __ ] piss and corruption
paved swamp hot mushy winds that never
cleaned anything away heavy thermal seal
over diesel fuel mildew garbage
excrement atmosphere a five block walk
in that could take it out of you you'd
get back to the hotel with your head
feeling like one of those chocolate
apples tap it sharply in the right spot
and it falls apart in sections
saigon november 1967 the animals are
sick with love not much chance anymore
for history to go on
unself-consciously
you'd stand there nailed in your tracks
sometimes no bearings and none in sight
thinking where the [ __ ] am i
fallen into some unnatural east-west
interface a california corridor cut and
bought and burned deep into asia and
once we'd done it we couldn't remember
what for
it was axiomatic that it was about
ideological space we went there to bring
them the choice bringing it to them like
sherman bringing the jubilee through
georgia clean through it wall-to-wall
with pacified indigenous and scorched
earth
in the vietnamese sawmills they had to
change their blades every five minutes
some of our lumber had gotten into some
of theirs
there was such a dense concentration of
american energy here american and
essentially adolescent if that energy
could have been channeled into anything
more than noise waste and pain it would
have lighted up indochina for a thousand
years
the mission and the motion military arms
and civilian arms more competent between
themselves than together against the
kong gun arms knife arms pencil arms
head and stomach arms hearts and minds
arms flying arms creeping peeping arms
information arms as tricky as the arms
of plastic man at the bottom was the
[ __ ] face grunt at the top of command
trinity a blue-eyed hero-faced general a
geriatrics emergency ambassador and a
hail heartless cia ambassador
all through the middle with the vietnam
war and the vietnamese not always
exactly innocent bystanders probably no
accident that we'd found each other if
milk snakes could kill you might compare
the mission and its arms to a big
intertwined ball of baby milk snakes
mostly they were that innocent and about
that conscious and a lot one way or the
other had some satisfaction they
believed that god was going to thank
them for it
we took a huge collective nervous
breakdown it was the compression and
heat of heavy contact generated out
until every american in vietnam got a
taste
vietnam was a dark room full of deadly
objects the vc were everywhere all at
once like spider cancer and instead of
losing the war in little pieces over
years we lost it fast in under a week
after that we were like the character in
pop grunt mythology dead but too dumb to
lie down
our worst dread of yellow peril became
realized we saw them dying by the
thousands all over the country yet they
didn't seem depleted let alone exhausted
as the mission was claiming by the
fourth day we took space back quickly
expensively with total panic and close
to maximum brutality our machine was
devastating and versatile it could do
everything but stop
as one american major said in a
successful attempt at attaining history
we had to destroy ben tray in order to
save it
that's how most of the country came back
under what we called control and how it
remained essentially occupied by the
vietcong and the north until the days
the day years later when there were none
of us
left there
and finally
little music
the disc jockey came on again
this one's a request for hardcore paul
and the fire team and for our groovy ceo
fred the head
hey mayhew turn that up turn it on up
hey coxsack you just told me to turn it
off come on man that's an out of sight
song
mayhew turned it up it still wasn't very
loud but it filled the bunker it was a
song that had been on the radio a lot
that winter
there's something happening here
what it is ain't exactly clear
there's a man with a gun over there
telling me i've got to beware
i think it's time we start children
what's that sound
everybody look what's going down
this cannot go on being a country
of torturers
it's time we stopped children what's
that sound
thank you